Alright, so let's take a moment to have a quiz where we
really delve deeply into what it means to have a best attribute.
So something Michael and I have been throwing around that term, let's
see if we can define it a little bit more crisply. So,
what you have in front of you are three different attributes that
we might apply in our decision tree for sorting out our instances.
So, at the top of the screen what you have is you
have a cloud of instances. They are labelled either with red x or
a green o, and that represents the label so that means
that they are part of our training set, so this is what
we're using to build and to learn our Decision Tree. So,
in the first case you have the set of instances being sorted
into two piles. There are some xs and some os on
the left and some xs and some os on the right. And
the second case you have that same set of data being
sorted so that all of it goes to the left and none
of it goes to the right. And in the third case you have that same set of
data that's sorted so that a bunch of the xs end up on the left and a
bunch of the os end up on the right. What I want you to do is to rank each one,
where one is the best and three is the least best attribute to choose. Go.